Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Have you ever wondered why we avoid certain feelings even when they keep us stuck
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。你有没有想过，为什么我们即使在焦虑、抑郁或身体疼痛中感到受困时，依然会回避某些感受？
in anxiety, depression or physical pain? In today's episode, we are exploring ISTDP, Intensive Short-Term Dynamic Psychotherapy with Dr. Suzanne Brown. This groundbreaking therapy dives deep and fast to break through the barriers holding us back from truly feeling our emotions. If you're curious about how ISTDP helps people face their fears, heal old wounds, and transform their lives, stay tuned because you won't want to miss this. Hi, welcome along. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you so much for being here. What an incredible episode we have lined up for you today. Dynamic therapy can get a bit of a bad reputation and I definitely think that it's one of the ones that makes people
在今天的节目中，我们将与Suzanne Brown博士一起探讨ISTDP，即“强化短期动力心理治疗”。这种开创性的疗法深入且迅速地突破阻碍我们真正感受情绪的屏障。如果你好奇ISTDP如何帮助人们面对恐惧、治愈旧伤并改变生活，请务必收听，因为你绝对不想错过。你好，欢迎收听。我是临床心理学家Marianne Trent博士。非常感谢你的到来。今天我们为你准备了一期精彩的节目。动力疗法有时名声不太好，我确实认为它是那种让人
think that you can read their minds when you meet them at parties. But today we're really having a close-up look at a modern dynamic therapy and frankly it's made me want to dive back headfirst into therapy to kind of explore what might be holding me back and how this might be affecting the relationships in my life. I would love to know how this resonates with you. What does this make you think about yourself? Please do drop me a comment, like, subscribe, share with your friends. Come and connect with me on socials too, where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. I cannot wait for you to hear, to experience this episode. I will see you on the other side.
在聚会上见到你时，会觉得你能读懂他们心思的疗法之一。但今天，我们正在近距离审视一种现代动力疗法，坦白说，它让我想要一头扎回治疗中，去探索是什么在阻碍我，以及这如何影响我生活中的人际关系。我很想知道这是否引起了你的共鸣。这让你对自己有什么思考？请给我留言、点赞、订阅并分享给你的朋友。也欢迎在社交媒体上与我联系，我在所有平台上都是Dr. Marianne Trent。我迫不及待想让你听到并体验这一期节目。我们稍后见。
I just want to welcome along our guest for today Suzanne, Dr Suzanne should I say. Hi Suzanne. Hi Marianne, thank you. Thanks for being here. We've been trying to catch up for some time and to be fully honest with our audience we first met when you were a trainee and I was qualified in an adult mental health service so that's where we first crossed paths but our lives have moved in very different directions since then and you've been doing some really exciting work. Could you tell us a little bit about you and your background Suzanne? Yeah so yes we did we met almost about a decade ago I think it was. So following on from training I went on to do additional training in America so I would fly out four times a year to Boston
我想欢迎今天的嘉宾Suzanne，或者我应该称呼她为Suzanne博士。你好，Suzanne。你好，Marianne，谢谢你。谢谢你的到来。我们已经有一段时间没见了，对听众坦诚地说，我们第一次见面时，你还是实习生，而我已经在成人心理健康服务机构任职了，那是我们最初的交集。但从那以后，我们的生活走向了截然不同的方向，你一直在做一些非常令人兴奋的工作。你能向我们介绍一下你自己和你的背景吗，Suzanne？好的，是的，我们大概是十年前认识的。培训结束后，我去美国进行了额外的培训，所以我每年会飞四次波士顿，
to train in a model called intensive short-term dynamic psychotherapy. And I was introduced to that on the training course actually, but I just kind of followed it and pursued it as an interest post-course and during it. And then very quickly after graduating, and actually, I think still whilst I was in training, I'd begun to liaise with a local football team, so Birmingham City Football Club. And then from there, it just kind of expanded. So I always tell people I kind of accidentally fell into sport. It was never an intention. I have family that work in sport, which is probably the link.
去学习一种叫做“强化短期动力心理治疗”的模式。其实我是在培训课程中接触到它的，但我只是在课程期间及之后将其作为一种兴趣去追求。毕业后不久，甚至我觉得还在培训期间，我就开始与当地的一支足球队——伯明翰城足球俱乐部进行联络。从那里开始，它就扩展开了。所以我总是告诉人们，我是“意外”进入体育界的。这从来不是我的初衷。我有家人在体育界工作，这可能就是联系所在。
And yeah, so following on from that, I very quickly went into private practice from graduating immediately. Actually, I did part-time NHS for a year and part-time practice. And then I took a position with Arsenal Football Club, working with the women's team, the first team, and have worked around sports so various different sports since rugby hockey some olympian work transitioning in and out after the olympics supporting players whilst they are at the olympics primarily it's been football and so most recently i was setting up the psychology department for Sunderland men's first team
是的，在那之后，我毕业后很快就进入了私人执业。实际上，我有一年时间是兼职在NHS工作，兼职做私人执业。后来我接受了阿森纳足球俱乐部的职位，为女足一线队工作，此后一直在体育界工作，涉及橄榄球、曲棍球，还有一些奥运选手的工作，在奥运会期间进进出出，主要是在奥运会期间为运动员提供支持。主要还是足球，所以最近我一直在为桑德兰男足一线队建立心理部门，
football club and yeah alongside that I guess I have maintained a private practice it's it's reopening now but have explored various different avenues and most recently and I would say returning much more to ancient methods of shamanic practice and sound healing and very much embodied practice of therapy so that's in a nutshell what's been happening in over the last decade oh amazing well you have been very very busy but also i've got a lot you've given yourself permission to do what excites and delights you and helps you get clinical results that really help people to thrive and I think that's admirable. Oh thank you I think the approach for me in terms of ISTDP my first introduction to it it was just
足球俱乐部。是的，除此之外，我想我一直保持着私人执业，现在正在重新开放，但我探索了各种不同的途径。最近，我可以说更多地回归了萨满修行和声音疗法等古老方法，以及非常具身化的治疗实践。这就是过去十年里发生的事情。哦，太棒了，你一直非常非常忙碌，但我也觉得你给了自己许可去追求那些让你兴奋和愉悦的事情，并帮助你获得真正能帮助人们茁壮成长的临床成果，我认为这令人钦佩。哦，谢谢你。对我来说，关于ISTDP，我最初接触它时，
an instant recognition really I would say of this is what I think therapy should look like right like this is um it just spoke to me at a very deep heart and soul level so yeah I just I knew I had to pursue it and then I was fortunate enough to go to a conference where I met Patricia Coughlin who became my trainer and later mentor. And again, it was a very similar experience of I must train with this woman. You know, I just have to do it. So I have always, I think, supported that intuitive side and leaned into that and more so recently. Incredible. Could you give us a brief overview, if that's at all possible, about the approach and kind of what people could expect in a nutshell
有一种瞬间的认同感，我会说，这就是我认为治疗应该有的样子。它在内心深处触动了我，所以我知道我必须追求它。后来我有幸参加了一个会议，在那里我遇到了Patricia Coughlin，她成为了我的培训师，后来成为了我的导师。同样，那是一种非常相似的体验，我觉得我必须跟随这位女士学习。你知道，我必须这样做。所以我一直认为，我支持并倾向于那种直觉，最近更是如此。不可思议。如果可能的话，你能简要概述一下这种方法，以及人们可以期待什么吗？
from it okay so it's it is a psychodynamic approach so if we kind of just start with the assumption that we believe in the unconscious right so that actually the majority if not all of our behaviors are driven from this unconscious place that then tries to link these two very important triangles and i think this is really important if i if you know people could know about one thing for me it would be the two triangles so the triangle of person so when you're working in therapy with somebody you're holding in mind uh the therapist you're holding in mind the relationship then and how that links to their current life situation, who's in their current life orbit. And of course,
好的，这是一种心理动力学方法，所以如果我们从我们相信潜意识这一假设开始，即实际上我们大部分甚至所有的行为都是由这个潜意识驱动的，然后它试图连接这两个非常重要的三角形。我认为如果人们能了解一件事，那就是这两个三角形：人的三角形。当你与某人进行治疗时，你心中要装着治疗师，装着此时此地的关系，以及这如何与他们当前的生活状况、他们当前生活圈中的人联系起来。当然，
where that stems from. So the past is kind of the other part of that triangle. And then what you're then mapping that across to is the triangle of conflict so you're thinking about these underlying feelings that at some point we have learned or been introduced to very very early on and in some way these are forbidden we should not have these feelings they should not be expressed and they can include any any feelings so rage grief sexuality joy pride you know people can feel anxious about any of those feelings and so that's the other part so feelings anxiety it gives rise to anxiety when these feelings start to to rise and break through into the the surface or the consciousness of the person and then they employ many and we we employ defenses to defend against that so we all have defenses
这源于何处。所以过去是那个三角形的另一部分。然后你将其映射到冲突的三角形上，所以你在思考这些潜在的感受，我们在很早的时候就学习或接触过这些感受，在某种程度上，这些感受是被禁止的，我们不应该有这些感受，它们不应该被表达。它们可以包括任何感受：愤怒、悲伤、性欲、快乐、骄傲。你知道，人们可能对任何这些感受感到焦虑。所以这是另一部分。当这些感受开始升起并突破到表面或人的意识中时，它会引起焦虑，然后他们会采用许多——我们都会采用防御机制来抵御这种焦虑。所以我们都有防御机制，
they're part of our normal psychological development but often they've become very rigid very crippling to the person so it's different and it deviates from normal psychodynamic therapies or maybe psychoanalytic tradition in that it welcomes resistance and it works specifically with resistance we work with defenses and we see that they are interconnected with that anxiety so there's a kind of a central dynamic sequence that we will follow but of course it's for me it's the ultimate blend of kind of art and science coming together our sessions are videotaped so we can review the sessions in between to see what we're missing and obviously we take that for supervision so we can have our own blind spots explored. But of course you're always responding to the person in front
它们是我们正常心理发展的一部分，但它们往往变得非常僵化，对人造成极大的束缚。所以它与正常的心理动力疗法或精神分析传统不同，它欢迎阻抗，并专门处理阻抗。我们处理防御机制，并看到它们与焦虑相互关联。所以我们遵循一种核心的动力序列，但对我来说，它是艺术与科学的终极融合。我们的治疗过程会被录像，以便我们在中间回顾，看看我们错过了什么，显然我们会将其用于督导，以便探索我们自己的盲点。但当然，你总是对面前的人做出反应，
of you so your intervention is always built upon the last response from the person in front of you. So it's very in the moment, very experiential. Thank you. I actually did my sixth and final placement in a service offering that. And yeah, certainly the triangles is bringing me back to that, the hidden desires, hidden feelings and all the conflict yeah and I guess as an aspiring psychologist being able to formulate from a variety of perspectives is so important and I remember having to try and get my head around these triangles I think for my first ever placement my first ever adult placement and being like having the book on formulation from Johnston and Dallas and and trying to get my head around Milan and his triangles and
所以你的干预总是建立在面前之人的上一次反应之上。所以它是非常即时的，非常体验式的。谢谢。我实际上在提供这种服务的机构完成了我的第六次也是最后一次实习。是的，当然，三角形让我想起了那些隐藏的欲望、隐藏的感受和所有的冲突。我想，作为一名准心理学家，能够从多种视角进行构思是非常重要的。我记得在我的第一次实习中，我试图理解这些三角形，我当时拿着Johnston和Dallas关于构思的书，试图理解Milan和他的三角形，
trying to make sense of it. But it's kind of, yeah, it develops. And I think being able to formulate like that really helped me think very deeply about the client. I'm feeling quite grateful that I didn't have to record my sessions, I think, as a trainee. Oh, that, yeah. I mean, I did actually on placement one one audio record some of my sessions you know it's all for learning isn't it it's all for our growth and for our clients protection and advancement in their therapy but it can make people feel quite uncomfortable I think it does ask of you to confront your own inner of course conflicts and I'm mindful like of using too much terminology but I guess that super ego part of ourself right our inner pathology our inner
试图理清头绪。但它确实在发展。我认为能够那样构思真的帮助我非常深入地思考客户。我很庆幸作为实习生时不必录制我的治疗过程。哦，那个，是的。我的意思是，我在第一次实习时确实录制了一些音频，你知道，这都是为了学习，不是吗？这都是为了我们的成长，为了客户在治疗中的保护和进步，但它确实会让人们感到非常不舒服。我认为它确实要求你面对自己内心的冲突。我注意不要使用太多的术语，但我猜是我们自我的那部分超我，我们的内在病理，我们的内在，
our own inner parts that again if we would kind of use an IFS term our own inner parts that are more critical are more harsh and of course it is a process I think I actually did start recording during my training. And I think that is exactly what you were saying to the point of what has enabled me to confront that is this deep desire to actually be able to give the person in front of me the best treatment possible. So I have to be able to see my failings and see my own contributions and the things that I haven't been aware of and might be being enacted.
我们自己的内在部分，如果用IFS（内在家庭系统）的术语来说，我们那些更具批判性、更严厉的内在部分。当然，这是一个过程。我想我确实在培训期间开始录音了。我认为这正是你所说的，促使我面对这一点的是一种深切的渴望，即能够为面前的人提供最好的治疗。所以我必须能够看到我的失败，看到我自己的贡献，以及那些我没有意识到且可能正在上演的事情。
And since obviously learning this model, it's just such an incredible way to then receive supervision and to be able to give supervision to others that are willing because you really have the material in front of you. There is no kind of distortion of this is how I think it went, or this is what I'm taking from it. So yeah, but it is a process and an inner journey, I think, and my own inner critic and having to meet that. And over the years, actually, actually yeah I think work with that and mellow it itself. Yeah and does that make supervision a lengthier process than you might typically have? No so it would be traditionally still well we would work to a 50 minute supervision but actually sometimes you might show the first three minutes of your supervision tape and you would spend the whole 50 minutes on that.
自从学习了这个模型，这真是一种令人难以置信的方式来接受督导，并能够为其他人提供督导，因为你真的把素材摆在了面前。没有那种“我觉得是这样”或“我从中得到的是这个”的扭曲。所以是的，但这确实是一个过程，一个内在的旅程，我想，还有我自己的内在批评者，我必须面对它。多年来，实际上，我想我确实处理了它，并让它变得柔和。是的，这会让督导过程比你通常经历的更长吗？不，传统上我们仍然会进行50分钟的督导，但实际上有时你可能只展示督导录像的前三分钟，然后你会花整整50分钟在上面。
Because actually, as we probably know, you know, that first opening gambit is so fully loaded, right? Often the person brings and I will start sessions without, you know, I'm not intervening. I'm waiting for the person to see what they're bringing. It's so full of material and content so we might just spend the first few minutes watching that other times you might jump through to a place of stuckness or you might jump through to this had an incredible effect and it you know we got a breakthrough and what did we do to get that? Because we want to maximize that. We don't just, it's not just looking at, right, what do I need to improve upon? It's what do I need to maximize?
因为实际上，正如我们可能知道的那样，那个最初的开场白是如此充满信息，对吧？通常人们会带来……我开始治疗时不会干预。我等着看他们带来了什么。它充满了素材和内容，所以我们可能只是花前几分钟看那个。其他时候，你可能会跳到一个卡住的地方，或者你可能会跳到一个产生了不可思议效果的地方，我们取得了突破，我们做了什么才得到那个结果？因为我们想最大化它。不仅仅是看“我需要改进什么”，而是“我需要最大化什么？”
What am I really good at that actually I need to lean into more? Because this has had a really great effect with this person. Absolutely. It's that tweak and refine, isn't it? Yeah, it reminds me of trying to almost have the intro session with a client beforehand and encouraging them to start the session because I think especially with kind of the fiduciary relationships of power people are used to deferring to the qualified psychologist or the position you know the person in charge and so for them to kind of be able to come in
我擅长什么，实际上我需要更多地投入其中？因为这在这个人身上产生了非常好的效果。绝对是这样，那是调整和完善，不是吗？是的，这让我想起尝试在治疗前与客户进行介绍性会谈，并鼓励他们开始会谈，因为我认为特别是考虑到权力的信托关系，人们习惯于顺从合格的心理学家或职位，你知道，负责的人。所以对他们来说，能够进来，
and think that they can start wherever they want to does mean you sometimes have to work with silence, which can feel triggering, especially as a trainee or a junior member of staff, I think. Yeah. So the initial trial therapy is what we term it. And actually that is an extended session. So that will be three hours long typically so you're having a three hour long session with somebody now in that first part you are really asking what's the problems that bring you here because let's be honest people don't know people come to therapy often because there is some suffering and so what we're really getting
并认为他们可以从任何他们想开始的地方开始，确实意味着你有时必须处理沉默，这可能会让人感到触发，特别是作为实习生或初级员工。是的。所以我们称之为“初步试验治疗”。实际上那是一个延长的会谈。所以通常会持续三个小时，所以你现在和某人进行三个小时的会谈。在那第一部分，你真的在问“是什么问题把你带到这里？”因为老实说，人们不知道。人们来做治疗通常是因为有某种痛苦，所以我们真正弄清楚的是，
clear on within that three hours they're having an active exposure to the therapy first off, right? It's, this is a joint assessment. Am I going to be a good fit for you as a therapist? And are you responsive to the model, right? How are you responding to the interventions? But for me, so much of that early trial therapy is being able to look at aspects that you're talking about there with whether it be compliance or defiance or passivity versus being active. And even that initial question, you know, what's the problem that you would like my help with? It really opens up the person in front of you's experience to dependency right am i going to depend on you
在那三个小时内，他们首先对治疗进行了积极的接触，对吧？这是一个联合评估。作为一个治疗师，我适合你吗？你对这个模型有反应吗？你对干预措施有何反应？但对我来说，那早期试验治疗的很大一部分是能够审视你刚才谈到的那些方面，无论是顺从还是反抗，还是被动与主动。甚至那个最初的问题，“你希望我帮你解决什么问题？”它真的打开了面前之人的依赖体验，对吧？我会依赖你吗？
and what has happened in my past with the people that i did depend on so you write into their attachment system as soon as they sit down opposite you really so yeah it's um so the first the first trial therapy would always ask that but and they would then be you know I suppose help to understand that subsequent sessions you are encouraged to be in the driver's seat because if I start the session we're working from my agenda and actually I'm here to help the person in front of me so I think there is a cognitive element to that because some people have never experienced therapy you do have to help them but mostly you know people have agency and they don't like to be overly controlled funnily enough we don't like that so yeah I think once once you're clear on that and the the task of therapy
我在过去与我依赖的人之间发生了什么？所以当你坐在他们对面时，你真的直接进入了他们的依恋系统。所以是的，第一次试验治疗总是会问那个问题。但他们随后会被……我想是帮助他们理解，在随后的会谈中，你被鼓励坐在驾驶座上。因为如果我开始会谈，我们就在按照我的议程工作，而实际上我在这里是为了帮助面前的人。所以我认为这其中有一个认知因素，因为有些人从未经历过治疗，你确实必须帮助他们，但大多数情况下，你知道，人们有能动性，他们不喜欢被过度控制。有趣的是，我们不喜欢那样。所以是的，我认为一旦你弄清楚了这一点，以及治疗的任务，
and the goals of therapy and the the way that you're going to get there then you're really off and you're into it yeah absolutely I think it probably takes a bit of unschooling actually to kind of work in this therapy model because even when I was an assistant you know you're encouraged to to kind of plan and prep for the next session ahead of the next one and you might kind of go in with a session plan about what you're going to do but this is like the opposite of that. You know, you've spent your time perhaps formulating. I remember writing process notes, things like that.
治疗的目标，以及你将要实现目标的方式，那么你就真的开始了，你进入了状态。是的，绝对。我认为这可能确实需要一点“去学校化”，才能在这种治疗模型中工作。因为即使在我做助理时，你知道，你被鼓励在下一次会谈前计划和准备，你可能会带着一个关于你要做什么的会谈计划进去，但这与此相反。你知道，你可能花时间构思。我记得写过程记录，诸如此类的事情。
But this is really seeing because you don't know what's happened in a client's life and what they've made of the previous session. And, you know, whether something's just, you know, blown up in their life or whether they've had that moment of breakthrough or clarity. So it's really allowing the client to be right where they're at then, not where they were last week. Absolutely. Absolutely. And it's such a good point because for me, and I know I've had supervision where I've then gone back into the next session thinking, right, this is how I'm going to intervene. These are the defenses that are in operation and I've got a different person in front of me. So all of a sudden, I'm relating
但这真的是在观察，因为你不知道客户生活中发生了什么，他们对上一次会谈有什么看法。而且，你知道，是生活中发生了什么事，还是他们有了那个突破或清晰的时刻。所以这真的是让客户处于他们当时所在的位置，而不是他们上周所在的位置。绝对是。绝对是。这是一个很好的观点，因为对我来说，我知道我曾有过督导，然后回到下一次会谈时心想：“好吧，这就是我将要干预的方式。这些是正在运作的防御机制。”结果我面前换了一个人。所以突然间，我是在与过去的版本建立联系。实际上，那导致了破裂。所以再次经过督导后，我能够回去说：“嘿，真的很抱歉。我是在与上周的你建立联系，我错过了你。我没有与你协调，这对我和他一起工作的这位先生来说非常深刻。”你知道，我不认为有人曾对他道歉，对吧？并真正承担起“我错过了你”的责任。但我确实认为，这很大程度上是关于治疗师是否愿意审视自己对情感亲近的障碍。我并不是说全部，因为我理解不同模型的多样性，但其中一些，
to a past version. And actually, that's caused a rupture. And so following supervision again, I've been able to go back in and say, hey, I'm really sorry. I was relating to past week you, and I was missing you. I wasn't attuning to you and that was just incredibly profound for this gentleman that I was working with you know he'd I don't think he'd ever had anyone say sorry to him right and take real ownership and accountability of I was missing you but I also do think a lot of this is about the therapist being willing to look at their own barriers to emotional closeness and some of that I'm not saying all of that because I appreciate the diversity of different models but some of
可能来自过度准备、控制、在面前放一张纸，因为它在建立一种阻碍，阻碍了与面前之人的接触、开放和可用性。我们能进行人与人、心与心、灵魂与灵魂的连接吗？很奇怪，我今天选择穿一件黑色高领毛衣，因为我从不穿黑色。我知道传统上，动力治疗师会穿非常素的颜色，他们可能会把头发扎起来，你知道，房间会很平淡，你知道，不会太分散注意力。你刚才说的听起来很有人情味，有一种真正作为一个人去连接的渴望，所以这听起来和你刚才说的很不一样，人们可能想象的那种弗洛伊德式的方法。是的，所以我的意思是，它源于弗洛伊德的第二个焦虑理论，但Habib Davinloo是那个真正
that can come from over preparation control bringing in a sheet in front because it's it's creating such a barrier to engaging and being open and available to the person that is just in front of you and can we connect human to human heart to heart soul to soul right it's weird that i've chosen to wear a black roll neck top today because i never i never wear black and i know traditionally kind of dynamic therapists would wear very plain colors they might have their hair tied back you know the room would be quite bland and you know not too distracting how does what you just said sounded quite human and a desire to actually connect as a person so that sounds very different than what what kind of people might be imagining about the kind of Freud approach to this yeah so I mean it it derives from Freud's second theory of anxiety, but Habib Davinloo was the person who really
采取了弗洛伊德理论的人。我想，他对这种无休止的分析概念有异议，那种会永远持续下去的分析，并说：“实际上，我们不必仅仅向阻抗让步。我们实际上需要能够利用阻抗来达到突破。”他受到了很多影响，甚至包括Eric Linderman的悲伤研究工作。所以他在椰林火灾灾难后与他一起工作。他能看到的是，这个外部事件引发了这种心理内部危机。这也是ISTDP理论的核心。我们如何促进心理内部危机，以便人们能够真正地保持……而且，我喜欢（你知道，我喜欢许多不同的模型，我正在进行我自己的荣格分析），所以我可以把它想成是，
took Freud's, I guess, he had an issue with this idea of analysis that was interminable, that would just continue on forever and said, actually, we don't just have to give way to the resistance. We actually need to be able to use the resistance to kind of get to a breakthrough. And he was influenced a lot by even like Eric Linderman's work of grief. So he had worked alongside him after the Coconut Grove fire disaster. And what he could see was that this external event gave rise to this intra-psychic crisis. And that is also at the heart of the the theory really behind istdp how can we facilitate the intra-psychic crisis so that the person can really be holding and and again that i love you know many different models i'm in my own jungian analysis so i can i can kind of think about it as
我们如何保持这些对立面的张力，对吧？就像我的一部分想要某样东西，另一部分不想要。但实际上，它旨在在可承受的范围内加强那种心理内部危机，对吧？我们正在追踪潜意识的焦虑路径，以便人们能够真正触及问题的核心。所以它绝对不仅仅是关于症状管理。它真的是在试图从核心解决这个问题，对吧？把人从痛苦中解放出来，这样他们就不会想要——用弗洛伊德的话说，你知道，“强迫性重复”——我们会找到一种方法，你知道，继续把痛苦和折磨带入我们的生活，因为我们没有意识到它。但你知道，我们参加的会议，因为素材显然是被拍摄的，我非常感激那些愿意分享这些素材的患者，因为这意味着
how can we hold the tension of the opposites of these things right like a part of me wanting something another part of me not but actually it's designed to to intensify that intra-psychic crisis within levels that are tolerable right we are tracking unconscious pathways of anxiety so that the person can actually get to the the core of the issue. So it's absolutely not just about symptom management. It is really trying to resolve this at the heart of it, right? Free the person from the suffering so that they don't want to, in Freud's terms, you know, the repetition compulsion, that we will find a way, you know, to continue to put the pain and suffering in our lives because we're not aware of it but it's you know the conferences that we we go to because obviously the material is filmed and i have such gratitude you know for the patients that are willing to share that material because it means
我们都可以学习。老实说，这是我在培训中见过的最真诚、最充满情感的素材之一。我喜欢保持对其他模式的了解和关注。但对我来说，这完全是关于与面前之人进行心与心的连接。所以这与你如果听说传统精神分析方法时可能产生的“白板”、“冷漠”的印象非常不同。是的。是的。好的。反思这一点很有趣。当你谈到为“错过”客户而道歉时，我感到了一种本能的转变，就像我在肚子里感受到了它。那是与另一个人连接并被视为重要，不是吗？你很重要，
we can all learn is you know honestly some of the most heartfelt-filled, emotional material I've ever seen across training. And I like to kind of keep aware and abreast of other kind of modalities. But for me, it is completely about kind of heart-to-heart connection with the person in front of you. So very different from that blank slate, cold, perhaps, idea that you might be having if you hear about traditional psychoanalytic methods. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. That's interesting to reflect upon. And as you were talking about apologizing to the client for kind of missing them, I felt that kind of a visceral shift, like I felt them in my tummy. It's that connecting to another person and being seen as important, isn't it? And that you matter
你可以对世界产生影响，你也可以对我产生影响。对于那些一直受困、冲突，并且可能没有得到最友善、最富有同情心、最积极回应的照顾的人来说，当你知道自己做错了，并且你并不完美时，告诉人们这一点真的非常非常重要。是的，绝对。就像被另一个人感动的能力，你知道，我想到我表现出情绪的时候，你知道，我会流泪，我会……这不是那种让对方觉得他们必须照顾我的方式，你知道，但实际上，这对人们产生了如此深远的影响。我记得在培训中，实际上，有一位女士，我被她的经历感动得流泪，我记得
and you can have an impact on the world and you can have an impact on me. And for people that have been stuck and conflicted and perhaps not had the nicest compassionate responsive care it's really really important to to let people know when you've got it wrong and that you're not perfect yeah absolutely and like the ability to be moved by another person you know I'm thinking of times where I will show emotion you know I will tear up I will have and it's not it's not in a way that the person then feels they have to take care of me or you know but in fact that has had such a profound impact on people and I remember in training actually with a woman where I had been moved to tears by her experiences and I remember
她回来时，她说了同样的话，就像“我对你有影响”。这完全震撼了她，她意识到她的经历，她的……你知道，她真正的痛苦、她的伤痛，可以被感受到、被接纳，并且不会让某人感到不知所措，而只是被承认和看见。所以我，你知道，我非常鼓励人们与那些情绪保持联系。这非常不同，你知道，如果我的反应是因为我自己的……你知道，它触发了我内心的一些东西。那么是的，我会想把它带到我自己的治疗或督导中。但我认为，能够足够开放去被感动，你知道，在情感层面上，这是非常不同的。因为，你知道，我们处理的是一个人最亲密、最深层的情绪、感受和体验。所以我们怎么可能不被感动呢？你知道，我有点困惑，
she came back and she said exactly that like I had an impact on you and and that had just kind of completely blown her away that she could that her experiences that her her you know really her suffering her pain could be felt and held and not not be overwhelming to somebody, but could just be acknowledged and seen. So I'm, you know, I'm very much, I encourage people to kind of be in touch with those emotions. It's very different, you know, if I was having a reaction that was perhaps something about my, you know, it has triggered something in me. Then yes, I would want to be taking that to my own therapy or supervision. But I think it's very different just to be able to be open enough to be touched, you know, at an emotional level. Because, you know, we work with the kind of the most intimate and deep emotions and feelings and experience of a person. So how could we not be in a way, you know, like, I'm kind of baffled,
我们怎么可能不被感动呢？是的，我想如果我们的听众听到这里，心想“那是移情吗？那是反移情吗？”但实际上你表达得很清楚，这不是你自己的东西被触发了。例如，如果我正在处理悲伤，它可能会让我想起失去父亲的事，但不是那样，这只是被你所听到的内容人性化地感动了。你是为那个人而感动，而不是为你自己。这就像，你知道，富有同情心，就像你在街上拦住某人说“你还好吗？你看上去不太好。”这是一种人际连接。是的，是的，绝对。而且我……
how could we not be? Yeah, and I think I'm kind of baffled how could we not be yeah and I think the if our audience are kind of hearing this and thinking was that transference is that counter transference but actually you're being quite clear this is this is not your own stuff being triggered so for example if I was working with grief it might be making me think about having lost my dad but it's not that it's just being humanly moved by what you've been told you're moved for that person rather than moved for yourself it's like you know compassionate like you'd stop stop someone in the street and go are you okay you don't look okay it's it's that human connection yeah yeah absolutely and i it's
这也是为什么，你知道，你自己的治疗和督导是必不可少的，这样你才能真正处理并继续处理我们自己所有的，你知道，关系模式、我们自己的失望、我们自己的痛苦、我们的悲伤，你知道，所有这一切。因为我们也是人，你知道，这没有什么不同。我和面前的患者之间没有区别。我们有我们自己的经历，我需要一个地方，就像他们一样。当然，但同样是为了我能为他们提供最好的照顾。所以不会发生某种反移情反应。或者，当它发生时，我可以回来说：“这是我在这件事中需要承担的部分。”或者，你知道，我正在反思这一点。有时你可以在会谈中完美地捕捉到它，对吧？你可能正处于我们认为的“投射性认同”之中。而你能够实际上，再次，你知道，如果你的焦虑调节得足够好，你能够实际上，再次，你知道，如果你的焦虑调节得足够好，
also why you know your own therapy in my, and supervision are essential so that you have really worked through and are continuing to work through all of our own, you know, relational patterns, our own disappointments, our own pains, our grief, you know, all of that because we are human too you know there's no difference there is no difference between me and the patient in front of me we've got our own experiences and I need a place just as much as they do of course but again so that I can offer the greatest care to them so there isn't some kind of counter-transference reaction going on. Or, and again, when there is, I can come back and say, this was my part to own in that. Or, you know, and I'm reflecting on that. And sometimes you can catch it beautifully in a session, right? You might be in the middle of what we would think about as a projective identification. And you're able to actually, again, you know, if your anxiety is regulated enough and you're able to actually again you know if your anxiety is regulated enough
你能够有机会看到正在发生的事情，然后能够将其带入会谈中。所以，“哦，我注意到我真的被拉入了一种感觉，像一个愤怒的学校老师，好像我在责备你。这里发生了什么？因为这通常不是我的反应。”然后他们可以接着说：“是的，你知道，那太真实了。我发现自己一直处于那种状态。”然后我们就进入了关于权威和围绕它的情结或冲突的事情。但对我来说，这只是，我们是否在自己身上做了足够的工作，
you're able to have access to to kind of seeing what is going on and then be able to bring that into the session so oh I notice I'm really being pulled into feeling like a an angry school teacher and like I'm telling you off and what's going on here because that's not usually my response and they can then say yeah you know know, that's so true. And I find myself in that all the time. And then we're into something maybe about authority and a complex around that or a conflict. But to me, it is just, have we done enough work on ourselves
作为心理学家，你知道，能够坐在另一个人面前，是的，去倾听他们的经历并真正被他们感动。是的，而且我认为我仍然认为我是对的，临床心理学没有要求你必须进行自己的治疗。所以在我的培训期间，有专业发展小组，这非常协调，非常和谐，在发展方面运作得非常好，而不是仅仅是冲突，那运作得非常好。但另一半学员有非常不同的经历，它感觉不安全，它不是
as psychologists as, you know, to be able to sit in front of another person and yeah, to hear their experiences and be truly moved by them yeah and i think still i think i'm right in saying that clinical psychology has no requirement for you to actually have done therapy of your own so during my training there was professional development groups which as was very well aligned and very harmonious and worked really really well in terms of development rather than just conflict that worked really well but the other half of the cohort had a very different experience it didn't feel safe it wasn't
一个适当的……你知道他们怎么说，“形成、风暴、规范”小组？它不安全，所以它不能那样使用。但咨询心理学家，我认为确实必须有他们自己的治疗，我认为这非常重要。在我的培训期间，我实际上也进行了分析，仍然有一些那种反思、领悟，它们留在了我心中。如果我诚实地说，我唯一不喜欢的是当我休年假时必须支付会谈费用，即使是提前几个月计划好的。而且我的治疗师会在那个会谈中坐着谈论或思考我的想法，这感觉有点不太人性化，你知道，因为这对我这个实习生来说并不是最便宜的
it wasn't a properly you know what do they say form stormed normed group like it was not safe so it couldn't be used like that but counselling psychologists I think do have to have their own therapy and I think it's so important during my training I actually had analysis as well and still some of those kind of reflections realizations they've stayed with me the only thing I didn't like if I'm honest is having to pay for sessions when I was on annual leave even if it was planned months in advance. And the idea that my therapist would sit and talk or think about me in that session, that felt a little bit not very human, you know, because this wasn't the cheapest of
过程。而且我认为它确实有一种倾向，在每周的日期、每周的时间段方面相当一致。作为服务的使用者，我发现这很难。你能在治疗中提出来吗？你能和他们谈论这件事吗？是的，它处理了我的一些愤怒。是的，完全正确。这就是重点，这真是一个很好的机会，一切都是机会，对吧？而且，是的，我不知道，我想在最初的契约中确实有某种东西，对吧？我们契约的内容是什么？我只记得说，你知道，甚至谈论依赖性，“我非常愤怒，我首先需要在这里。”你知道，它真的……它真的引发了我自己的依赖性，
processes for me as a trainee. And I think it does have a tendency to be kind of quite consistent in terms of day of the week time of the week slot I found that hard as a user of the service. Were you able to bring it up in the therapy were you able to talk about it with them? Yeah it worked with some of my rage. Yeah exactly right and this is it it's just such a good opportunity like everything is an opportunity right and yeah I don't know I guess there's something in that initial contracting right like what are we contracting to and I just remember saying you know in that even like talking about dependency like I'm just so rageful that I need to be here in the first place and you know it really did it really kind of brought up my own dependency
我心想：“我相当自给自足，谢谢。天哪，现在我必须依赖某人。”然而，它确实成为了与他人最丰富的关系之一，但也实际上促进了与我自己最丰富的关系。但我可以理解这一点，显然……我想这就是为什么成本非常不同的部分原因。在精神分析中，它比在临床心理学中往往要低得多。是的，我不知道，我认为这几乎有一种……对我来说，这关乎承诺，对吧？我已经承诺了这个过程，现在如果我不能参加，因为我的工作时间表是……好吧，实际上，我……是的，我
and i'm like pretty self-sufficient thanks and i have gosh now i've got to rely on somebody and yet it has become absolutely one of the richest relationships with another but also actually to facilitate the richest relationship with myself so but i i can appreciate that and obviously um i think that is partly why the costs are very different it's much lower in psychoanalysis than it tends to be in clinical psychology yeah I don't know I think there's almost something of like to me it's something about the commitment to right like I have committed to this process and now if I'm if I can't make it because my work schedule is well actually I'm I'm kind of, yeah, I'm
放弃了对自己的承诺，但我有另一个人，我对他有承诺。所以我鼓励处理愤怒，对吧？我们最终会到达那里，通过这样或那样的途径。所以，是的。是的。而且，你知道，我现在是自雇人士，所以我现在也明白了。但是的，就像……是的，谢谢。谢谢你问那个问题，因为这本身就非常有趣，而且看到那个过程上演，就像……是的，这是
abandoning the commitment to myself, but I have got somebody else who I'm committed to. So I encourage the working through of the rage too, right? We get there eventually, one route or another. So, yeah. Yeah. And, you know, I'm self-employed now, so I do get it as well. But yeah, it's like, yeah, thank you. Thank you for asking that question because that's really interesting in itself and kind of seeing that process play out like yeah it's
重要的事情，它可以真正帮助人们改变他们的生活，改变他们的人际关系，这样他们就不会只是在那个仓鼠轮上转圈了。是的，我喜欢……你知道，这总是像……我想这很讽刺，不是吗？我们知道，比方说，研究表明CBT治疗师会去找动力治疗师进行他们自己的治疗。而我接受了强化短期动力心理治疗的培训，我……我在长期，我已经进行了七年了，你知道，就像……我只是觉得这真的很有趣，不是吗？关于我们如何被吸引，也许这其中确实有一些相当完整的东西，以及那种健康的一面。而且我认为它确实可以改变人们的生活，而且它确实归结为
important stuff and it can really help people to change their lives and change their relationship so that they're not just going around on that hamster wheel really yeah and I love you know it's it's always like I guess ironic isn't it that we know let's say for instance the research says CBT therapists go to psychodynamic therapists for their own treatment and I trained an intensive short-term dynamic psychotherapy and I I'm in the long term I'm seven years in you know like I just I think it's really funny isn't it of how we are drawn to maybe there is something quite whole about that and kind of a wholesome aspect of that and I think it can truly change people's lives and it does come down to the
使治疗有效的共同因素，对吧？这就是为什么我是一个支持许多不同模式的人，因为实际上有很多方法可以有效。这实际上更多地与治疗师的契合度有关，而不是模式，以及它对个人感觉有多真实，我认为这才是真正改变生活的。但人们也确实有很多糟糕的治疗经历，对吧？如果不提这一点就太失职了。所以是的，是的，绝对。如果……如果你要与一位未具名的专业人士合作，这与坐在私人执业的患者面前没有什么不同。所以我正在尝试理解什么是问题，我能如何提供帮助。然后不可避免地会出现阻抗，对我或对他们自己的阻抗，
common factors actually that make therapy effective right that's why I'm you know a big supporter of many different modalities because actually there's many ways to be effective it's actually more to do obviously with things like therapist fit and rather than the modality and how authentic it feels to the person and which is what is truly life-changing I think but also people do get a lot of experiences of bad therapy right like would be remiss to not mention that too so yeah yeah absolutely and if if you were to be working with an unnamed professional be no different to being sat down with a patient in private practice so I am trying to understand what is the problem and how is it I can be of help and then what will inevitably arise is resistance resistance to me or resistance to themselves
关于获取更深层的情感。当然，这确实会转化，它会涟漪般地扩散到你的生活中。所以我想到一个实际的例子，你知道，他们与教练有冲突，他们如何解决这个问题？因为他们可能是高绩效者，但他们正在失去从教练那里获得一些重要信息的机会，或者他们让他们保持距离，或者他们对他们采取回避态度。这不可避免地，而且已经……（我在这里想到现实生活中的例子），但你知道，当然与过去的人物、过去与权威人士的经历有关，在那里他们受到了虐待、失望。所以在这个意义上，我们能够坐下来面对对那些人的感受，这真的没有什么不同。
about accessing deeper feeling and of course that does translate it ripples out into your life so i'm thinking of an actual literal example of you know they're having conflict with the coach and how can they resolve that because they might be a high performer but they're losing out access to maybe some important information from the coach or they're keeping them at a distance or they're being avoidant with them that is inevitably and has you know I'm thinking of real life examples here but you know is of course related to past figures past experiences with those in authority where they have been mistreated or disappointed or so it's really no different in that sense of us being able to sit down and face the feelings towards those people
关于触及更深层的情感，这当然会转化并波及到你的生活中。我想到一个具体的例子，比如他们与教练发生了冲突，他们该如何解决？因为他们可能是一名高绩效者，但却无法从教练那里获得一些重要信息，或者教练与他们保持距离，又或者他们在回避教练。这不可避免地——我想到的是现实生活中的例子——当然与过去那些权威人物、过去那些曾虐待或令他们失望的经历有关。所以，从这个意义上说，我们能够坐下来面对对那些人的感受，其实并没有什么不同。
so that they don't keep getting anxious in response to these feelings and then doing all sorts of defensive behaviors like acting reckless and getting a red card and being sent off or going out and drinking and eating badly which you know is not on their plan and is going to sabotage their you know desires to be a better performer but also affect their performance and impact the team but that's just one example say because my experiences and I think a lot of sports psychologists would at times or have echoed this with me that you know there are mental skills that can be very helpful but in my experience people um just don't use them right they've been taught them and unless you're getting through and you're able to break through that resistance that is you know sometimes at the
这样他们就不会因为这些感受而持续感到焦虑，进而做出各种防御性行为，比如鲁莽行事、吃到红牌被罚下场，或者出去酗酒、暴饮暴食。你知道，这不在他们的计划之内，会破坏他们成为更好运动员的愿望，也会影响他们的表现和团队。但这只是一个例子，因为我的经验，而且我想很多运动心理学家有时也会与我产生共鸣，那就是有些心理技能确实非常有帮助，但在我的经验中，人们并没有正确使用它们。他们学过这些技能，但除非你能真正触及并突破那种阻力，而这种阻力有时正是
heart of the self-sabotage they aren't going to use the the things that are available to them so we've got to first deal with that otherwise you know you can teach them tools you can talk at them but it's not going to be of much help so i try to weave in these principles both in the one-to-one work but i will run emotional fitness classes which also tries to normalize you know if you're human this is going to relate to you you know other humans you're human this is going to relate to you you know other humans you might find this useful so we might talk about boundary setting and obviously you do need good access to healthy anger for that right you need to be able to say no and set a boundary and assert yourself if that boundary is violated or transgressed at other times you're
自我破坏的核心，否则他们是不会使用这些现成工具的。所以我们必须先处理这个问题，否则你教给他们再多工具，对他们说再多话，也不会有太大帮助。所以我尝试在一对一的工作中融入这些原则，我还会开设情绪健康课程，试图让人们意识到：如果你是个人，这些感受就与你有关。你可能会发现这很有用。所以我们可能会谈论设定界限，显然你需要有健康的愤怒来做到这一点，对吧？你需要能够说“不”，设定界限，并在界限被侵犯时维护自己。而在其他时候，你
gonna you're gonna lose that championship game and you're going to be devastated and if you're blocking your grief to that you might find that actually instead of moving through grief you got depressed right isn't it going to be important for us to help you access the grief instead of going to a depressed position so it's just so relevant because fundamentally we're emotional creatures right so you can't dissect this from any aspect of our life. Oh, Suzanne, I feel like I want to have therapy with you now. It's making me think of a game I watched recently or a snippet of a game I watched recently where there was a biting incident or what looked like a biting incident.
会输掉那场冠军赛，你会感到崩溃。如果你压抑了对那场比赛的悲伤，你可能会发现自己没有走出悲伤，反而陷入了抑郁。难道帮助你面对悲伤而不是陷入抑郁状态不重要吗？这太重要了，因为从根本上讲，我们是情绪化的生物，所以你无法将其从我们生活的任何方面剥离出来。哦，苏珊，我现在真想找你做心理咨询。这让我想起最近看的一场比赛，或者比赛片段，里面发生了咬人事件，或者看起来像是咬人事件。
And it absolutely made me in a football game case and not familiar with what I'm talking about somebody I think is what making me think we became frustrated and angry and acted out with their teeth and it made me think about what I used to say to my children we keep our teeth away from people even when we're cross you know it's that very basic rule but also the word bite for children. It's quite fun, isn't it? Bite, bite, bite. But, you know, it's about thinking about when you're told no, how do you respond? You know, my little boy, my youngest used to take himself to the porch and headbutt the wooden floor because he knew that was a behavior mommy couldn't ignore.
这绝对让我在足球比赛中……如果你不熟悉我在说什么，我想那个人是因为感到沮丧和愤怒，用牙齿发泄了出来。这让我想起我过去常对孩子们说的话：即使我们生气，也要把牙齿远离别人。这是一个非常基本的规则，但对于孩子来说，“咬”这个词很有趣，不是吗？咬，咬，咬。但这是关于思考当你被拒绝时，你如何回应？你知道，我的小儿子，我最小的孩子，过去常跑到门廊上用头撞木地板，因为他知道那是妈妈无法忽视的行为。
He probably knew mommy was a psychologist and she was weird about brains. You know, how are you gonna, how are you gonna perform and carry yourself when you're told no, or when you're dealing with big, big feelings? Yeah. And when the opponent is purposely trying to, you know, get you going, is using material that is going to aggravate you, is, you know, going to get you mobilized or the referee isn't going to you know fairness is a big thing and obviously from a very young age children are very in touch with fairness and justice and if that has been violated at a young age you can see where these conflicts arise right so the ref gives you know an unfair card or a penalty or whatever it might be.
他可能知道妈妈是心理学家，而且对大脑很敏感。你知道，当你被拒绝，或者处理巨大的情绪时，你会如何表现和自处？是的。当对手故意试图激怒你，使用会让你恼火的手段，或者裁判……你知道，公平是一个大问题。显然，孩子们从很小的时候就对公平和正义非常敏感。如果这种公平感在幼年时期受到侵犯，你就能看出这些冲突是如何产生的。所以裁判给了一张不公平的牌，或者判了一个点球，或者其他什么情况。
And I think I know, I think there's been a couple of biting incidents in, I mean, I'm also thinking of the quite famous boxing incident where, I guess we won't name people, but yes, it does happen. And we would, of course, be thinking of that as an acting out. So this is not, that is more defensive behavior because the anxiety is so dysregulated that they might be feeling a primitive rage right that is very primitive the the desire to bite and like you're talking about this is the other beautiful thing that i'll often talk about you know when people say i'm not an angry person or uh you know like um well you weren't born like that because if you look at children they are absolutely in touch with the full force of their raw feelings and i have two kids and i am bitten
我想我知道，我想在拳击比赛中也发生过几次著名的咬人事件，我想我们就不提名字了，但确实发生过。我们当然会认为这是一种“宣泄”行为。所以这不仅仅是防御性行为，因为焦虑已经严重失调，他们可能感受到了一种原始的愤怒，那种想要咬人的原始欲望。就像你说的，这是我经常谈论的另一个美妙之处。当人们说“我不是一个爱生气的人”时，嗯，你生来并非如此，因为如果你观察孩子，他们完全能够感受到原始情感的全部力量。我有两个孩子，我被咬过
regularly marianne i you know with both of them they did you know my older one has moved out of that but my younger one does and he had butts and he pinches and he claws. And actually it's so primitive that that pathway is there with us right from birth. And then over time, we learn that in order to preserve the connection, to preserve the relationship to the people we need the most, I'm going to have to suppress this. Mom, dad, teacher, coach can't tolerate whatever the feeling is. So I learn eventually just to not even notice I'm having the feeling, but maybe, and this I think is quite chronic, people are aware they're anxious. Or other times they've just become so used to that anxiety, they think that's how I am. So if I think, I can tell you I've worked with professional footballers that will say to me, when the ball is at my feet, I have ringing in my ears, my vision is blurry. That is an extreme level of anxiety. They're still performing at a very high level, but you imagine the energy that is then freed up when they've learned to regulate their anxiety they've looked at the feelings that are generating that they've got
很多次。玛丽安，你知道，他们两个都这样。我大孩子已经过了那个阶段，但我小儿子还在经历，他会用头撞人、掐人、抓人。事实上，这种路径从出生起就存在于我们体内，非常原始。随着时间的推移，我们学会了为了维持联系，为了维持与最重要的人的关系，我必须压抑这种冲动。妈妈、爸爸、老师、教练无法容忍某种情绪。所以我最终学会了甚至不去注意自己有这种感觉。但也许，我认为这相当普遍，人们意识到自己焦虑，或者他们已经习惯了那种焦虑，认为自己就是这样。所以我可以告诉你，我曾与职业足球运动员合作，他们对我说，当球在脚下时，我耳朵里有嗡嗡声，视线模糊。那是极度的焦虑。他们仍然在高水平比赛，但你可以想象，当他们学会调节焦虑，审视产生焦虑的情绪时，他们会释放出多少能量。
an absolutely different level of clarity and ability to perform they're already performing at an incredibly high level but they're absolutely crippled with anxiety you know so yeah i think it's just i mean it's essential in all areas but we we often have conflated rage and anger with the actual destructive acting out. And I think it takes a lot of just normalizing to people how, yeah, it's a very human, normal reaction. And part of what is quite well known, I think, in ISTDP is this idea of portraits. And maybe that would be referred to as active imagination in Jungian psychology, which is the invitation to face and feel the feelings, right? So actually to be able to portray what exactly you would like to do that is a world away from doing it. So just like I might say to my son, yeah, you do really want to hit your brother, but we't right like it's it's okay to have the feeling but it's not okay to act out and lash him you know lash lash out on him so yeah oh it's so
他们会获得完全不同层面的清晰度和表现能力。他们本来就已经在高水平比赛，但却被焦虑彻底摧毁了。所以我认为这在所有领域都是必不可少的。但我们经常将“狂怒”和“愤怒”与实际的破坏性行为混为一谈。我认为需要让人们意识到，这是一种非常人性化、正常的反应。在ISTDP（强化短期动力心理治疗）中，有一个众所周知的概念叫“肖像法”。也许在荣格心理学中这被称为“主动想象”，即邀请人们面对并感受这些情绪。所以，能够描绘出你到底想做什么，这与真正去做是两码事。就像我会对儿子说，是的，你真的很想打你哥哥，但我们不能这样做。拥有这种感觉是可以的，但付诸行动去伤害他是不可接受的。所以，这太
so interesting so interesting thank you Suzanne is there a right or wrong stage for people to start learning about this in their career are the books that people can kind of start reading before they begin any kind of training is there you know I know that for example they don't let you train in it until you're a final year trainee are there any similar rules for this no so I mean there's a lot of books out there so my kind of I suppose the people that come to my mind are of course, Patricia Coughlin. She has a number of books. Alan Abbas is very well known in the field. He has a number of books. John Fredrickson is again, very well known in the field. Josette Tenhab de la Bige and Robert Naborski have collaborated on books. the thing I would say is this is a lifelong model right so I think
太有趣了。谢谢你，苏珊。人们在职业生涯中开始学习这些知识，有没有所谓的正确或错误阶段？在开始任何培训之前，有没有什么书可以先读？我知道，例如，他们不允许你在最后一年实习生之前进行培训，这方面有什么类似的规则吗？没有。有很多书可以读，我想到的当然是帕特里夏·考夫林（Patricia Coughlin）。她有很多著作。艾伦·阿巴斯（Alan Abbas）在该领域非常出名，也有很多著作。约翰·弗雷德里克森（John Fredrickson）在该领域也非常出名。乔塞特·滕哈布·德拉比格（Josette Tenhab de la Bige）和罗伯特·纳博斯基（Robert Naborski）合作过书籍。我想说的是，这是一个终身学习的模型，所以我想
what can happen and this is a I suppose something we're mindful of and we speak about in the community quite a lot is that you can get so excitable when you come across this material and you see the videos and they look incredible right I mean it's just fireworks on on kind of the screen and because they have been practicing for decades it does look seamless but of course they will talk to you about you know I could have gone off on this junction I could have gone here instead there's not a perfect way of doing it but I think then the tendency is to rush in and try to apply these practices. And then it can go very badly, right?
可能会发生的情况是——这也是我们在社区中经常提醒和讨论的——当你接触到这些材料并看到那些视频时，你会感到非常兴奋，它们看起来太不可思议了。屏幕上就像放烟花一样，因为他们已经练习了几十年，看起来确实天衣无缝。但当然，他们会告诉你，我本可以在这个节点走另一条路，我本可以去那里。没有完美的做法，但我认为人们往往会急于应用这些实践。然后事情可能会变得很糟糕，对吧？
Because this is a very potent model. And so I think there needs to be an adequate respect for learning that and taking the time. And so the way that you train in the model, you do go into a core training, which is three years. And then after, you know, I've done advanced training after that and then I stay in contact with peer groups and I seek out supervision and but it's it's really getting your head around this is a lifelong learning this is not going to be you've done the three years and you're good to go and that I I think the principles are great but the way that you learn it is that you actually take your videotaped material and you show it to every block
因为这是一个非常有力的模型。所以我认为需要对学习它保持足够的尊重，并花时间去沉淀。你接受该模型培训的方式是参加核心培训，为期三年。之后，我进行了高级培训，并与同行小组保持联系，寻求督导。这真的是要让你明白，这是一项终身学习，不是说你完成了三年培训就万事大吉了。我认为这些原则很棒，但学习它的方式是你必须拿出你的录像资料，展示给每一个小组
so you're constantly getting feedback in real time of the material that you're showing and it did really feel like a group psychotherapy process as well Patricia is particularly skilled at being able to kind of bring that group dynamic process in so you again it's kind of like you're having your own therapy alongside it but of course you know there's a lot of material out there she's also on youtube so are so is john frederickson michelle may is releasing a book that i think is going to be very accessible so if people want to kind of have a read of it and how it's applied i guess from her own life and as a therapist and being in therapy yeah like and
这样你就能实时获得关于你所展示材料的反馈。这感觉也确实像是一个团体心理治疗过程。帕特里夏特别擅长引入这种团体动力过程，所以你就像是在接受自己的治疗。当然，有很多材料，她也在YouTube上，约翰·弗雷德里克森也是。米歇尔·梅（Michelle May）即将出版一本书，我认为会非常通俗易懂。如果人们想读一读，了解它是如何应用的，我想可以从她自己的生活以及作为治疗师和接受治疗的经历中了解。
go to a conference that's where you're really going to get to see that material so um I think I was introduced to it on the doctorate I saw a video and I signed up to a conference in Sweden I was like right I've got to see more of this this is the soonest conference I can go to but go to a conference you know um yeah see what you you make of it. But I guess I would just encourage like a healthy caution that, you know, we can get really carried away with this. But, you know, I wouldn't want anyone to have too much hubris in thinking it's an easy model. It is very complex. Yeah, it sounds it.
去参加会议，在那里你才能真正看到那些材料。我想我是在博士期间接触到它的，我看到了一段视频，然后报名参加了瑞典的一次会议。我当时想，我必须看到更多，这是我能参加的最早的会议。但去参加会议吧，看看你的感受。但我还是想鼓励大家保持一种健康的谨慎，我们很容易被这些东西冲昏头脑。我不希望任何人因为认为这是一个简单的模型而过于自负。它非常复杂。是的，听起来确实如此。
But you have made it sound, I don't know, you're obviously just a master in your field. I've loved know, you're obviously just a master in your field. I've loved chatting with you. How can people learn more about you and connect with you on socials if they want to, which I'm sure they will? Oh, thank you. Well, I am not super active on socials. It is something I need to get better at, but you can find me at the website www.emotionallyconnected.co.uk. I am on X and I am on Instagram and we are definitely looking going into next year. I am partnering with some professional dancers to kind of bring very much this embodied psychology to life. So one of the hopes is that we will have for professionals only workshops that kind of bring together we're calling it at the moment story body soul work and it's really going to
但你让它听起来……我不知道，你显然是该领域的专家。我非常喜欢和你聊天。如果人们想更多地了解你，并在社交媒体上与你联系（我相信他们会的），他们该怎么做？哦，谢谢。我不太活跃在社交媒体上，这是我需要改进的地方，但你可以在网站www.emotionallyconnected.co.uk找到我。我在X和Instagram上都有账号。我们肯定在展望明年，我正在与一些专业舞者合作，将这种具身心理学带入生活。我们的希望之一是，我们将举办仅针对专业人士的研讨会，将我们目前称为“故事、身体、灵魂工作”的内容结合起来，它真的会
integrate story work with embodied movement practice sound healing and yeah encouraging people to of course grapple with themselves because of course who you are determines everything that you're able to bring into the world so if people want to register interest they can reach out and email me. That sounds amazing I will absolutely be on the waiting list for that. Thank you so much for your time I've loved chatting with you what an absolute privilege to have spent this time with you and yeah I feel like our audience are incredibly lucky to have had you as a guest because yeah you've just been wonderful so thank you well thank you for what you are doing and bringing many voices to this space so it's very much needed so I appreciate
将故事工作与具身运动实践、声音疗法结合起来，鼓励人们与自己搏斗，因为你是什么样的人，决定了你能带给这个世界什么。如果人们想注册意向，可以联系我并给我发邮件。听起来太棒了，我绝对会加入等待名单。非常感谢你的时间，我很喜欢和你聊天。能花这段时间和你在一起真是莫大的荣幸。我觉得我们的听众能有你作为嘉宾真是太幸运了，因为你太棒了。谢谢。也谢谢你所做的一切，为这个领域带来了许多声音，这是非常需要的，所以我很感激
I appreciate you having me on thank you and on brand I will say thank you Suzanne that makes me feel very seen very important thank you you're welcome oh gosh what an amazing experience that was speaking with Dr Suzanne please do go and follow her on socials and check out her website too what do you think to this episode has this wet your whistle to learn more has it made you think about the importance of accessing your own therapy? Or perhaps you're accessing this episode because you are considering ISTDP as a therapy approach for yourself. Has it sealed the deal for you? Please do let me know. Drop me a comment. If you're on Spotify, you can drop a comment as well and if you're on apple podcast please do rate and review wherever you get your podcast please do follow the show it really is the kindest thing you can do for totally free for any podcaster that you appreciate
我很感激你能邀请我。谢谢。作为品牌的一部分，我要说谢谢你，苏珊，这让我感到被看见，非常重要，谢谢。不客气。天哪，与苏珊博士的谈话真是一次美妙的经历。请务必在社交媒体上关注她，并查看她的网站。你对这一集有什么看法？这是否激发了你学习更多的兴趣？它是否让你思考了接受心理治疗的重要性？或者也许你收听这一集是因为你正在考虑将ISTDP作为自己的治疗方法。它是否让你下定决心了？请务必告诉我。给我留言。如果你在Spotify上，也可以留言。如果你在Apple Podcast上，请务必评分和评论。无论你在哪里收听，请务必关注这个节目，这对任何你欣赏的播客创作者来说，都是最友善且完全免费的支持方式。
if you would like to come along to the aspiring psychologist community which is my free facebook group and is the exclusive home of Marianne's motivation and mindset sessions. Please do so. You'd be so welcome. Thank you so much for being part of my world. If you'd like a little bit more and you're ready for the next step, please do consider the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join for just £30 a month with no minimum term. And you can always access all of the replay content since the launch of the membership too. Please do check out the Aspiring Psychologist book and the Clinical Psychologist book. There may well be another book on the way at some point soon too.
如果你想加入“有抱负的心理学家社区”（Aspiring Psychologist Community），这是我的免费Facebook群组，也是“玛丽安的动力与心态课程”的独家基地，请务必加入。你会受到热烈欢迎。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你想要更多内容，并准备好迈出下一步，请考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），每月仅需30英镑，没有最低期限要求。你还可以随时访问自会员计划启动以来的所有回放内容。请务必查看《有抱负的心理学家》（Aspiring Psychologist）和《临床心理学家》（Clinical Psychologist）这两本书。不久之后可能还会有另一本书问世。
You heard it here first. I love providing this content content for you please do let me know what you think and if you wanted to buy me a cup of tea to say thank you there's a link in the description for how you can do that or there's a link on any of my socials for my link tree too if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical
你在这里先听到了。我喜欢为你提供这些内容，请务必告诉我你的想法。如果你想请我喝杯茶以示感谢，描述栏里有链接，或者我的任何社交媒体链接树（Linktree）里也有链接。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这个播客成为你的指南，有它在身边，你就能走上获得资格的道路。这就是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫贾娜，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床
psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现关于不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。成为临床心理学家的途径之多让我感到惊讶，没有完美的途径。这让我充满了信心，觉得我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。